hi everyone welcome to biology professor
today i'm going to show you guys how to
use a q-tip
to
hand pollinate some tomato plants so you
can see i've got two tomato plants
there's one there's another
it's november right now we're inside
these plants would die outside i don't
have bees or other pollinators in my
house so i have to use these let me show
you how i do it so usually i would use
two hands i would use one hand to kind
of stabilize each flower because they
are a little fragile and the other hand
to do just what you see here i'm just
going back and forth from flower to
flower even moving from one tomato plant
over to another tomato plant
transferring pollen from the center of
one flower to the center of another
flower i'm using the same end of the
same q-tip repeatedly you might do this
every two or three days to ensure
pollination but ultimately the goal is
just to go back and forth and to
introduce pollen from one flower to
another and you should even see a little
bit of yellow on the end